welcome to this video playing f ms.m 3-m
from japan what is this we get into a
French okay let's see find some sideline
here that I usually play from somehow
stumbling into this opening night f3
okay divide that a slowish kind of lame
Bishop to h4 okay and put a weird way to
play really not quite sure what the
sugar is doing on h4 in this position
okay I'm just playing with knives IAM
voluntarily place that interesting
Jeff now black has a slightly better
pawn structure here let's see if I can
do something with that mean it's not
like white is lost or anything but it's
really comfortable now preparing c5 okay
the easiest is just to take on c4 c4 is
also interesting and then 95 but I think
taking is probably really the simplest
way to proceed now this gap I have the
two against one now and gives me a
passer I don't understand any move here
why a five okay
yeah they are lost the last three or
four games in a row and if I'm not
winning this I'm pretty ending this
session couldn't really what okay so g4
yeah okay I cannot understand that white
is switching to desperation mode but so
still hard to believe her so what to do
night is 725 or something maybe okay
let's let's get rid of the Queen's IAM
it's not even able to take on age six I
believe so yeah well I'm taking that
poem sweetie no reason not to so night
26 is this something that is up to I'll
be here right
so I can take yeah Jay let's take I can
keep g5 with f6 if I like I'm not sure
isn't drooped c6 move maybe this one
just try to win that that a 6 pi k still
as possible 90 60
okay let's push this he goes 96 I was
thinking night c7 and grabbing grabbing
a 6 mm yeah this I was thinking f6 let's
do that
okay see no not really rook be five I
won't be five i can go look b6 it's not
really a problem so let's advance this
okay so what now night c4 try to okay I
really push the push the porn quickly 97
and 93 this doesn't that mean let's
let's do this and see how to do this now
kinky seven probably just advancing here
right if five and then possibly to to
see 60 maybe just push it right I mean
like be three king king b6 it's 97 97
anyway okay I can go back but it's not
so easy now to see a win why well how do
I win would be three maybe just pushing
you can also go over but then slide c5
let's do this check I wonder if I should
go Knight f3 yard or back and let's
let's see that I wind up on down where's
King be five so dangerous I'm really not
quite sure going back
I thought night before no and then
Becca's good time or ain't jack let's do
that no night be seven maybe I and beg
to c5 check I asked up 95 this no
now we cannot move the night out anymore
that's probably not the best technical
play over him
let's take some stuff check check your
had to be seven in case of a seven so
don't you force coming I really played
that bad lame bad technical plane 96
maybe or something
winning autumn ashamed but that wasn't
really great Jack Jack White for its own
time yeah but bad technical flame should
have been a pretty simple window and
game and I didn't manage it didn't make
didn't look very simple yeah I was I
didn't understand any of that that that
whole said I was kind of wrong I mean at
least it's an ambitious I'd say I'm just
why do I if I take yeah I don't know why
don't a white cake with the points not
necessary okay well and him here black
is slightly better because after c5 that
pawn structure will favor me in some
some way so I was surprised that he so
yeah deliberately gave me that porn and
so on that could be porn why do I play a
four a five it just helps black and here
yo the engine is on mine is too weird
just to put it into perspective it
actually wants to just push the bleep
horn and ignore all of that now better
this is not bad technically it's it's a
solid plus two advantage but I really
played that badly probably missing some
some easier wins the night end game
should be should be simple but somehow I
at least if I'm leaving engine
I haven't screwed anything up up yet
well maybe it wasn't bad i don't know I
here here here it's equal and here it's
equal I have to do now G form but why is
it equal a check exactly 96 check 95-94
supposed to be equal but if I got me
five you just did yes and here I'm even
using amazing I have to go here to avoid
that check check it is just a random
computer line with the draw yeah no 1
i'm somehow winning again yes i agree
it's difficult to chapel to play off
this lip ok thanks for watching